all right everybody were like hearing
from sage summit 2016 in Chicago with my
friend Stephen Kelly second time we're
doing the live version of it yes I'm was
out on him um yeah and we did one didn't
we in Nolan's first of all to do that I
go no i don't i don't think was one of
these things yeah i think ron was our
first one yeah so we're here to talk
about how to ignite your passion we've
got some special guests coming in we've
got a whole audience over here too if
you guys have questions for us make sure
to leave it in the chap in the comments
and we can answer them for you before
getting started I want to show you
something this came from one of our
loyal a google hangout chat followers
man i made this t-shirt you talked about
the heart the head in the heart so we
put that you can't wanted here where is
it here the head and the heart and then
they ask Cal great Logan yeah so this
way I'll show you guys sure that this is
a also from gr eyes that's focusing on
me me back that it won't do the
autofocus but it's got that the head and
the heart in the hashtag s Kelso the
fans the fans like I think the a scale
is going to stick people are loving on
over the flow so talk to us help ash is
what we're here for what what's your
advice for entrepreneurs on how to
connect with their passion and then turn
it into something that they can build a
real business offer yeah you know we we
know you know if you follow your dreams
receives passion w laughs but doing it
really excited by or find a gap in the
market was a lot of pain then you've got
a business and you and you can make that
business ideas your farrier and you can
make it very personal to you and add
your personality to that product or
service so I'm pursuing your passion is
fundamental I thing here honestly I've
been a business a long time Evans you
lot younger than me but you've got to be
passionate about what you're doing
because you you're always about
authenticity and integrity as great
leaders are and I think if you don't
love what you're doing and you don't
really care about it it's really tough
to get up early in the morning and work
18 hours a sometimes and you've got to
have that far in your belly to really
make a difference and build a great
business so here we are in say summin
this
to be honest last year I'm ever not met
in New Orleans we had about five
thousand people at the last section of
it this time is probably fifteen
thousand it's crazy eyes unbelievable
I've never a but it's just got as though
it's a conflict with a real personality
so check it out I mean safe calm and
then probably either they / summit or
whatever you check it out look go on the
website and watch some of these large
days we just had an amazing life sweet I
session on stage with the shark tank
guys I'm Robert and then just blew it
away they just said so much common sense
of you sometimes forget when we run the
business because your heads down flat
out days of emotional rollercoaster ups
and down and sometimes you just need to
lift you it heads up reflect a bit and
say what's kind of going well what about
what am I here for and you've got to
come back to your passion which is the
essence of why you do what you do cool
well that the chair is blowing up people
saying they love you and I'm scrolling
through pages of comments here uh let's
get to some of them so Tamara is saying
Yahoo we can feel like we're it's a
somewhat today for 30 minutes thank you
over this even for your time today can't
wait sook shams I gotta look over here
to see the questions question what
should you what would being interrupted
where we gotta go we go Jeremy hey the
other thing what it have to before the
end of the show what can we get kind of
the webcam up just corrected ransom you
guys just can't believe this age village
out there wiki is rocket will join me
someone really tired i know i mean i
know i posted on my chair we might do
that later but we got special guests
we've got all the way from the united
kingdom a rockstar entrepreneur Jeremy
corner or surprise blue eyed son coming
no you said let's get love it just just
this guy's is the king of photobombing
day I manages the work is wearing
everything Jerry here I know he did a
little recap this morning at five thirty
or somehow we got some t-shirts too
we're good okay those are sweater is
going on these are Stevens daughters and
my uncle my girls in yeah future hey by
the way too serious guys hey you must
love this all right
site branded low ambassador look at that
look at that inside of my jacket by the
way maybe good sorry driving I'm gonna
die will wear the sage green we get
alarmed here we go quick costume change
so it is boiling in here in Chicago by
the way we got whatever time but we do
it showing stuff you guys out well this
is this fits well there we go am i right
future entrepreneurs feeling more
British now just wearing eyes and dream
of striking it man this is the idea okay
guys this is a serious show here here's
a serious channel we know a lot free
Barrabas well with you this could be a
filthy a band I'm gonna start a band
okay question what what should we do to
be passionate every day and how do we
bring crashing into our employees what
are you ready Joe me ABBA so I just
thought take this ass done got few me
like that me to me it's a question again
nice well Jeremy just tell the audience
what was your business what's your mojo
was so I have a greeting card business
in the UK called blue-eyed son and a
wedding station is described Yellin and
our passion is connecting people we call
it old school social media we want
people to kind of connect type
meaningful relationships and feel good
about one another using cards it's
really nice to send and receive cards so
yeah that's our thing charged yeah
relationship thing I comedians I uniting
parts is my main thing so you know I
want people to feel like you know closer
to one another I love it I've known this
guy a couple years and i've got i've
seen these products are using products
they're awesome game on online thank you
and it's a great husband wife
partnership yeah that's right yeah if
you're in the states you can buy them in
papyrus stores some target stores and if
you're in the UK you can buy them in
Waitrose and jaundice and no sup Market
stores like that when you guys see the
vlog come out of my experience here
you're gonna see this guy like half the
clips he's he's my agent on some video
clip he's stalking me well okay at all i
knows my husband this camera just came
up outside the window is very
embarrassing I don't know how what's the
15th
like that outside me let's get to some
question the question okay we have a
question erosion okay what do we do to
stay passionate every day and how do we
bring passion to our employees so bring
passion every day and how to make our
employees passionate really like us yeah
that's a good question i think you know
you got our focus I like Evans thing
that you choose as a single word so like
believe and we do book coming out on
that I'm looking forward to reading
about that actually I did something
similar called the core process where we
have to my two words are uniting arts so
on a daily basis you kind of think well
is this uniting hearts from the mi with
my team and I uniting hearts with or
what we're doing over uniting hearts is
it focusing on what we believe in so I
think having a kind of way of focusing
and something that you really is a
mission that you believe in the coffee
bean I wave of thing that I'm doing it
and practicing a daily you know being
mindful of this yeah and I say yeah
you've got to be true to yourself again
you've got to believe in morning where
your passion is and then you can
actually with the energy that you've got
and the belief of the essence of that
that's very easy to become infectious
and your colleagues will absolutely film
same fashion you do and it's age you
know it's all about supporting
entrepreneurs the true here is the
economy bring all the growth and
prosperity and we'd have simple traits
like user business builders we want you
to build on and we want you to have
awesome technology as you deserve
because you guys wrong simple as that
yeah and for the second part about
bringing it to your employees I think
you got to hire for that too when most
people just hire for skills very like I
need a new programmer so some of those
PHP I'm going to hire that guy but they
have to be on board with the mission
right like if somebody tries to work for
sage and is doing an interview with SQL
over here and doesn't love entrepreneurs
they're not getting in yes if you don't
you I'll be honest if you don't love
customers in our company you shouldn't
be that you should go yeah what's the
government and so Steve not interested
in evidence gets his tattoo and I get
these tech you can tattoos on his
employees with believe but actually one
of his team has believed tattooed on AI
love that story anything you're not
taking that back to the UK I mean I'm
rolling out running out the thing on you
know touching and then you need to get
yours done it's all right and I think
yeah the other thing were would you know
scale business I've started businesses
I've scaled one thing and it's easy to
stop by maybe on a Friday night you're
late after every but a beer just ask
your first six colleagues well then
really believe it what drives what is
the mojo what is the escort isn't DNA of
the company and how do you describe a
set of values and culture some behaviors
write it down and then stay true to that
even when you're 60 employees and 600
employees and then you know when you get
to that scale you had a 20 30 40 but
start saying right we're going to do a
half days of induction orientation
process bring people in and say this is
what sleep and even in the interview
process you know we believe you do the
right thing customer first and honestly
it people don't share those values they
shouldn't be here so it's really
important thing you have that common
bond of a family and you said that as
the leader you said that the entre known
and that's your stamp that is your your
mission is connected to a passion you've
got to get your green in there man
there's no reason to live here they
getting covered there you go missing a
pain on the way I don't know why guys
okay next up is Richard the
million-dollar question is how does one
stay focused and on and determine with
their goals when everything seems to go
wrong I usually focused and determine
everything seems to go wrong true yeah
that's our operations I might be out of
chicken you know reality chicken what I
did was a startup business entrepreneur
leader chicken segment back in
California I had months where I'm really
worried about not making payroll every
day every day god I remember into so on
vividly it was an emotional
rollercoaster ride and some days I used
to say bike today was a great day three
steps forward two steps back but some
days it was two steps back there was a
lot of good news and then would land a
big order and then we wouldn't have
enough people in business would go crazy
or hiring and then you know it's the
schizophrenia as a leader you you can't
free your colleagues out and share this
stuff for them since one day you
throwing your scale it up you're hiring
people and then if the kind of order
pipeline dries up leaving wow we need to
take costs down and there is that
schizophrenia you need to dementia but
how you manage that number one I think
you need strong as a promotional is that
it back to your passion back to
connecting you with Michigan is then you
know it's worthwhile and you can't
expect anything special nice to be
created from anything apart from a
really good mission short of tremendous
national and then fun put all your
energy into execution and hard graft
will never hurt anybody honestly and
promise you that and I don't know
anything really special sustainable you
create apart from a really awesome
execution and hard work and unless you
win the lottery or something you know
but otherwise you don't do that if you
don't do anything special and create
something unique and magical and as you
really execute it you've got to say to
tell you truly cool yeah I mean I think
like you gotta that's that's really good
advice I mean I think and you know you
when I find it difficult and when things
go wrong for me it's I actually really
sort of thrive on that and get excited
because it's you know you move forward
from pain so you know if sales are down
and you're having a tough year you know
you just go back to all that I always go
back to the basic so it's like you know
are we are we delivering the right
products to our customers at the right
price you know are we keeping touch with
in the right way what are our
competitors doing are they doing
something better than us at the moment
that we haven't noticed you know and
then sometimes it can be outside your
control so you can't control the economy
you know ensor so you have to pay
attention to those things and you can't
win economies are struggling or you have
difficult times like you don't know
what's going to open the UK i'm looking
at abroad at the moment because you know
there's lots of opportunity for us
abroad with the pound changing and all
that kind of thing so I think I'm you
know makes you more resourceful it's
like you know that we were talking this
morning that you know just entrepreneurs
they kind of if you want to do something
like we like we wanted to do things
today where we wanted to get places and
you know we wouldn't take no for an
answer right so you've got a pretty much
you know listen guys I'm really sorry
but I've got it I've got a panel and
going to dash must be lovely sunny time
avoiding injury much there but mayor
pointed jack
thank you yeah yeah thank you babe you
have a premium quick stage change there
we go and I think the other thing
obviously we talk about this in previous
kind of google hangouts and laughs find
someone you trust who's been through
your journey before and you know just go
for a coffee with them and just just be
honest with yourself and ask for advice
when your face I'm really tough times
and the good news is in business
everything can be overcome with great
determination conviction and belief and
if you still believe in your passion and
you've got an awesome product there's
always where you can find to grow and
actually Jeremy's point is the answer is
never more resources it's all about
resourceful pneus resourcefulness and
it's an entrepreneur you've got bundles
of resourcefulness I would say to like
to add to both both of the points are
you got to enjoy the process you know
you have to enjoy the work not just be
attached to the outcome a lot of people
i have a goal i want to hit this things
where I want to be and I'm going to do
all this crap to get to that goal but if
you don't enjoy the work then when you
don't hit that goal that's super
frustrating you're going to quit or the
most successful entrepreneurs yeah we
have goals we have big do we want to hit
this milestone you know I want to hit X
you know in a million subscribers on
youtube but it's not the point i'm not
doing stuff just to hidden lint
subscribers on youtube I like the crap I
like making these videos I like making
stuff for you and I find when you don't
enjoy the process of your business then
it's really hard to stay motivated so
you know there's going to be a lot of
down days you may not get that yes from
the customer and that's understandable
like you're gonna get down on yourself a
little bit but what gets me back in is I
just drive back into the work like I'm
going to make another video because I
love it right I get hugs from my work
right it feels my soul so like so you
have to be doing something that you love
and not just do a bunch of crap to get
to that goal enjoy the process and the
process keeps you through the thing that
gets you through the crap of building
the business is enjoying the craft yeah
otherwise you're like you're crazy you
know you you are crazy you have to be
crazy to do all the things that you have
to do to get to where you need to go and
the only thing gives you two is the love
of the work yeah
and actually this probably is not
helpful at the moment when you're facing
a crisis but honestly when I've been in
crisis and I've got really really bad
days weeks months called it when I look
back on my career I learn more in those
times and I've had in the good times and
you gotta have some you gotta you know
sometimes we been in the ring with kind
of whatever the fodder is we've got a
great cage fighter here dry and Stan and
Mike Tyson whoever it is you've got to
take a few punches and it makes you
stronger as an entrepreneur more
Brazilian I'm more able to cope but you
need to pause and having got through
that reflect on what do you learn and
what do you do differently next time
because it's all about becoming a better
option grown the journeys never finished
perfections not possible on this planet
sadly but if you learn from these times
you can really prospering and I have the
business situation where sometimes
business ventures have failed but from
the learnings of those failures you
actually come back stronger with a new
idea and then that's a rape and success
love people are seeing s Cal always on
fire on purpose I like it I think we got
to watch out about our hand movements
war with the people yeah I the camera
shakes we get excited that happens our
hands move yeah honey come we're back
with Natalia blood in it we just like to
talk about hat well I'm half Italian
anyway d live is writing in asking how
to unlock I want to unlock my inner
ability how do i unlock my in your
ability I think you know I tell you this
guy is great because that would believe
I see so many amazing entrepreneurs who
just sometimes lack conviction and
actually just I've got a great guy
Lorenzo we might give a shout-out get a
loan to come and hit right come out come
over back to say can wait but learns
ease up from San Paolo we happened to be
here he's dad email me said you know you
do this amazingly cool say summit
Lorenzo can you come and do a day's work
shadow yeah of course why would I say no
but there's a thousand kids out there
probably you come from disadvantaged
backgrounds who either haven't got the
milk
confidence or conviction or just to say
Steven can you do this but there's you
know found something like Evan always
key word is ask ask heart and it's all
about belief it's all about conviction
and if you do that you'll explode your
inner passion and it able to externalize
it and really get people on your kind of
movement and your crusade had to follow
you your customers and partners your
colleagues and everybody out there on
social media as well to really be part
of your volunteer army to build your
success Thanks there you go um I think
if you don't know what your inner
ability is yet you need to explore you
have a try stuff I think people get
locked in too quickly on a career path
that is not the one that's meant for
them and it may be because your parents
want you to do that you feel stressed
out that you know you're 20 years old
and don't know where you're going to go
just as an example what's your favorite
sport I'm gonna be Blue Jays now I'm
converted baseball no I probably hockey
I'm field hockey field hockey okay
what's 12 it cuz i play that they can
you last year I played field hockey I
love stockbroker she'll add john i'll be
on the seven i love Eddie school
anything with a ball in it I love it
okay so you know I love it let's go
let's go soccer because it's kind of
hormone us who do you think is a
greatest soccer player of all time um
that's a great question i would say
probably petty la okay so and you know
Pillay whether he's number one where
these number three whatever ride like
this always in the list i would say that
pili is not the number one soccer player
in the world of all time the greatest
player of all time is a manager at
starbucks because he never picked up a
soccer ball yeah because he never
explored does he never try cuz he got
stuck on a path yeah and then never went
out to explore his options and so like
that guy could be Pele a greater but
he's not he's doing some menial job or
low-level job or middle management job
right the point is you you guys could
all be the Pele of something and you got
to figure out what that is and you do it
by exploring
and not settling like if you wake up
when you look in the mirror and that guy
got to go do another day of this like
that's not the right thing to do you got
to go and find something else and takes
a lot of guts and courage to not know
what you're going to do next but know
that what you're doing right now isn't
enough and so if you don't know what
your inability is that's great you got
to have the courage now to go and try
different things and see what makes you
come alive and the thing that you love
doing even doesn't make any logical
sense like maybe you're too tall to be a
jockey or you're too short to be a
basketball player or whatever like don't
let that stop you from potentially
finding your greatness because you could
be la at something instead of doing what
you're doing right now yeah I think um
we got some amazing sort of explorers
hair talking about the parallels in
terms of entrepreneurship and exploring
an adventurous so got a great guy just
in time sure who's climbed Everest
sailed around the world he's taking
loads of disabled service people off to
the North Pole on expedition South Pole
and the reason why I'm telling that is
because none of these guys thought it
was possible to do what they've done and
I think entrepreneurs would encourage
you to be adventurous explorers and
reach through your eyes climb new
mountains and unless you climb them you
will never know and then the the biggest
tragedy about life is you kind of sit
there one year 50 60 70 80 and said I
wish I'd done that you can grab the
opportunity old Latin bit of carpe diem
seize the opportunity seize that moment
give it a go no one's gonna die if you
fail and I've felt loads of times and
stuff I've done and I've always learned
more and become a better on from there
and I just think we would say
entrepreneurs the spirit of adventure
and the spirit of exploration has to be
in your heart and that fuels your
passion love it next one coming in I
want to know how do you overcome fear
some day I hope you can I said okay who
dey how do you overcome fear hey you day
um you know I actually have used it for
that amazing guy dr. King Martin Luther
King and he says if you wanted you want
to climb the giant golden staircase you
have to take the first step
and there's you know amazingly symbolic
but you have to take the first step and
I tell you what right so if you have to
fire an employee don't do on a monday
because i guarantee you'll spend the
whole weekend worrying about it and then
you won't have that conversation and
tough conversation and then you push it
out and you'll let the performance issue
fester and you've just got to take these
things head-on and you've got to be true
to yourself and you've got to be honest
to yourself but it's always about you
just take in that first step so how do
you overcome fear the only way you do it
is practice practice practice practice
practice using this board analogy it's
not because that they're gone starbucks
he didn't have the chance but also the
best you know there's in these sports
the difference between the best golfer
in the world and the person who plays at
100 is like less than one shot handicap
and what is it it means and they've all
said rory mcilroy you know I get lucky
and more I practice the more I get lucky
and this practice the more you practice
the more you fail the more you
experience the more you explore the more
you adventure the more you have
conviction of relief and that is the
best way to overcome fear I think with
fear too I think people feel like
they're not supposed to be afraid like
beer is normal when you're trying
something new and you don't have
experience and you're going to be afraid
it's feeling that fear and doing it
anyway and the thing at least that helps
me get through it is I try to imagine
myself when I'm you know 80 years old
looking back in my life by the time I
get there I'm I'm I'm when I'm on my
deathbed it might be like 200 years old
by the time I get up there with all our
technology and everything but you know
I'm on my deathbed looking back on my
life and I want to have a few regrets as
possible and that's the thing that helps
me get through my fear like will I
regret not doing this well I regret
bowing down or bowing out or not talking
to that person I'm not taking my chains
will I regret it and yes it's super
scary but for me that feeling of looking
back in my life and feel like I'm gonna
regret not taking this shot now that
gives me the courage to be
that fear and then once you do it once
it's just like training the muscle
becomes a lot easier the next time we do
it's easier the next time you was easier
for me speaking on stage I was super
nervous the first time I did it I
secretly hoped that they would call me
and cancel and say lists it happen you
know conferences off don't worry about
it they go great you know but didn't
cancel i went and and I was super
nervous but now the next conference
becomes easier the next comes becomes
easier and you know maybe when I'm
speaking in front of a stadium of 50,000
people maybe I'll get nervous on that
one right but then the next time do that
it'll be easier and so to seek this
point about practice practice practice
like you just take the first step and
then the next step becomes easier and
the next that becomes easier and that
huge thing that is insurmountable is now
broken down hey I'm going to add one
Hannah a bit of shameless Navy up and we
had cuentas culture here and after they
had a conversation with them and we're
talking about shoe store my house you
should go obviously a very successful
business and she loves an actress an
incredible actor but in terms of one of
the aspects you sort of struggle with
initially but she's now absolutely kind
of militant about is planning and
there's a will give you something and we
talked about it before the power of
visualization this is the in terms of
planning you check it out on the web as
well there's a phrase called in state
planet and it's used to sport in
business and everything so Usain Bolt he
doesnt sit down in the locker room and
it's a dark locker room is quite as
iphone on listening to music what he's
doing is imagined himself crossing that
on for me the line faster than V else
and he actually goes back every 10
meters and it mentions exactly what he
does so if you fear anything the best
way to overcome it is practice and the
best way without the actual practice is
visualization but you always start with
in 2n say planning start with you to 100
meters you've got a hundred thousand
people in Rio at the Olympics cheering
you screaming your name and you ask what
did I have to do every metre of that
journey me 299 meter 98 neither how did
I come out of starting blocks and then
you visualize you you play the movie in
your head you know what the answer is
and you just hit the blocks and you just
go for gold so it's really bad there's
also this arm you can teach yourself
this is really cool there's a single
future perfect past tense
so you actually and it could be like a
business meeting could be a pitch it
could be a presentation so you do a
presentation you say write what I want
to do is come out of that room with a
presentation done for a sales order
where I've got those prospective
customers clapping cheering and
applauding and show me love and say they
want to buy my fries we got a view
product then think about what is it we
would have had to done to achieve that
so what we will it will have had to have
done Tookie success what what do I need
I've got the order in my hand I've left
the meeting the CFO signed the paperwork
there and then because you loved my
product so much so what were what would
we have had to done to assure him of
that what is his issues are going to be
and then smash it his issues and just
imagine yourself plan that movie and
even you know test drive it with a buddy
so I want you to see it between your six
you know prospect customers and just run
through do a dry run and and you always
get feedback to improve but key about
the power of visualization it transcends
for it transcends business imagine
you've ended up with huge success with a
huge smile on your face and your
customers with Raven fans and walk out
with that order just think about what it
would have taken because if you think
about the other way around you sit here
I'm going a big pitch I'm going to try
and sell you know fifty thousand dollar
piece of equipment or whatever and all
you think is oh my god that's so scary
but if you think wow we've done it we
got the deal smashed it knock them all
out the park mentally your whole fear
dissipates away and then it's always
about the plan for success and then you
can be successful I'm going practice and
do it it's a lot of passion I feel like
we might spontaneously combust in this
room it's exciting what was something
you were afraid of recently um like that
when you started but like yesterday or
last week you're getting ready for
summer actually I'll tell you so I'm in
New Orleans Evan was with us last year I
just fell this was very what would
created through sage summers me
special and it was uni there's loads of
conferences all over the world but for
entrepreneurs to come here meet amazing
speakers like its last shot at one
league those guys gave such practical
advice to entrepreneurs starting off and
they reconnected the audience to when
they started and what mistakes they made
and what experience and then there's
loads of teaching sessions there's loads
that we got a session on how to use
Pokemon go in your business to drive
marketing you know crazy but you would
have thought about six weeks ago but now
how can you jump on that amazing shift
in terms of biggest trend that's going
on around the world over the last couple
weeks so there's really practical things
as well as how to raise finance all that
sort of stuff but um what I want to say
it is in your lives at 5,000 people and
it was special because it had that
uniqueness and everybody who kind of was
connected and I worried coming into this
a lot now 15,000 is huge who are amazing
celebrity speakers we've got the killers
tonight the band of the concert on the
shores of Lake Michigan and interview if
you've nearby will find some way to get
you in there right you're crazy but
drop-top my buddy here a text or
something we'll try and find somebody to
get you in because Brandon Flowers
Achilles awesome man I was worried with
15,000 people that we'd lose that
personality lose their intimacy lose
that connectedness to everybody so
everybody needs save something feeling
very special and that they got massive
value from their investment of time of
three days because if you're an
entrepreneur to come to conference like
this not just the airfare on the hotel
and stuff like that three days out the
office I know you kind of got email
social media stuff you can stay in touch
with people but it's still a big
investment of their time and I feel very
plus the eyes my mission to make sure
everybody gets value out of this and I
just felt with 15,000 be we might lose
that intimacy and I have to say I was
wrong on that we managed to keep it but
some of these conferences where you go
and there's tens of thousands of people
you know people just feel like they're
kind of rabbits and you know it's that's
no good we want everybody to and it's
like social media it's one-to-one
conversation we want everybody to feel
special but we overcame it and we just
cracked on but I was worried about it
about two weeks ago
myself what about if a lot of these guys
come along and they just say actually
last year was that mm disappointed great
so am is it better this year yeah yeah
everything is that end that for me let's
start tank true but yeah it's good no I
like it I get to see a lot of you guys
fans to make videos it's great no it's
good it's been it's been a lot of fun
it's been a lot of fun move time for
more and then we're bumping up against
it far you do one more I want to do
until then I'm going to shave ing I'm
not too crazy this no no I think we
should do it g rise ask the question
he's going to make the shirt but love
and Jen rod you get the logo do yes I
feel like we gotta we gotta answer
question okay last question in J reyez
he's saying is it ok to have periods
where you don't feel passionate or feel
passionate about doing nothing yeah why
did I understand actually I was on the
stage with a guy called Sir Richard
Branson ooh my culture reference what a
duty ones as well and so humble he's got
such a sense of humility he's so
grounded attention are it was amazing
but I just think I asked her the
question you know he was his first
business from 2016 he's now think 66 50
years of being an entrepreneur and he's
had hundreds of brands across what
virgin america least down music verge of
Music sign people up Rolling Stones sick
fest all of these pants I'm so many
business I like to ask him there must
have been times where you had really
dark here as you career and you lost
that you know since it have with your
sense of passion was doused and your
heart you know struggle so how did you
overcome that out of your bounce back
and I think it does come back to what we
talked about you've got to have that
sense of passion that sense of go from
that mission the noble cause that you
want to create the reason why you know
you see a gap in the market you're angry
or there's pain and you can solve that
and inevitably you know we're all human
beings and we all have some bad days and
sometimes we get knocked off I'll kind
of mission when you do that again I
think you need some people around it
where you can just have the honest
conversation and you
always fine when you talk stuff through
it's never as bad as it seems and then
that gives you the courage to come back
and push you your noble cause yeah I
think it's okay to have some down days
like I don't want to paint it to be this
rosy picture everything is amazing all
the time and you always win but if you
are down for too long like if you are
not motivated for too long if you look
in the mirror and you're you're
depressed for too long then something
probably has to change you know I have
down days in my business you know the
video that we put up I didn't like as
much as it because it could be you know
perfectionist and want things to be
better always I want to have a bigger
impact always but i still love what i do
a lot and then i get lost in the work
again so back to like loving the craft
pounding on it beatin on it loving what
you do and not being so attached to the
results so yes you're going to have down
days but if you don't on your surface
like if that happens too many days in a
row then something probably needs a
shift in your life somewhere yeah and
and always I think about like we only
get one shot I mean out of it but it's
great to be optimist and I think your
optimism particularly when you start
employing people and you growing
optimism is contagious and people will
look to you and when you walk in on a
monday morning leave on a friday they'll
know whether you walk in with a bouncing
year your stride or whether you walk
with your head down and your heart sunk
they'll feel the energy and i think
there's a leader inherently tivoli there
is a correlation between optimism and
success and you've got a obviously not
just customers partners keeping social
media but our ultimate your colleagues
at your colleagues love your mission and
your passion they'll follow you to the
ends of the earth and if you you
actually praised them and give them the
tools to be successful and surround them
with optimism then and i'm looking to
you kid yourself in genuine optimism is
a great power and a force for good cool
cool you join yeah it's a mentality
crazy at dinner whether we can do this
but you stay here like we're going with
climbing in the student if no expense
spared now I don't know what
we see I don't know I can't see what you
can see but we're going to just give it
a go providing head with velvet gotta do
is it look good morning hey I don't want
the other side but man I don't know what
you can see there can you see it you see
it guys will do it to another would hey
hey man I think oh man I know I'm up
here you go I've got the angle run I'm
we're back we're back look at that I
don't how many people around there but
its body and their sessions is now it's
refreshments is great teaching sessions
there's loads of entrepreneurs out there
and they're on fun the whole conference
theme is igniting your passion so and
we're living at eight where there is
good guys I'm not sure what you can see
that but you'll tell if you give us some
real time feedback and I'll just pass
over Evan to wrap up igniting your
passion hey guys you're passionate
you'll see on the vlog what Stevie just
did but he's straddling one leg on a
chair the other on the table to really
give you guys the infant's going on so
that's how much he cares about letting
you guys see and sharing um awesome I
you know I know you guys were a little
upset about it only been half an hour
this week but see was got an insane
schedule and you gave us some extra
bonus time today so we'll appreciate
that thank you guys for watching we'll
see you again next month continue to
believe leave the stage see this is
believe it's the airplane taking iron we
need a sage gesture it's important we're
gonna work on that ignite to the moon
and beyond alright whatever day ago I
haven't come up thanks guys today's guys